Oh
[Music]
[Applause]
for much of human history the idea of
physical proximity and attentional
proximity we're seen as one and the same
where I am is what I pay attention to
who I'm with is who I pay attention to
but the notion of who I'm with the
notion of where my mind is is being
transformed in the back of wireless
technologies who are you where are you
when you're talking on the telephone
are you at the other end of the world
and someone else is here or are you over
here essentially attentional proximity
on the back of these technologies has
been disjointed from physical proximity
our mind and no longer has to be
engaging with where we physically are at
our mind has been unhinged liberated
from the constraints of time space and
distance we have transcended geography
now granted we are still interfacing
with other minds transcending physical
proximity physical location with you
know magical devices made of plastic and
metal but eventually full immersive
virtual reality the ability to engage
with somebody on the other side of the
planet in a space that isn't space that
nonetheless feels like a
three-dimensional matrix will lead to a
time when the new thing is going to be
called shared co-presence it's this
notion that mind-to-mind communication
and mediation will be free of any
constraints this is a kind of kind of
technologically enabled transcendence of
over matter mine Trump's matter mine
Trump's biology mine
Trump's any and all limits you know and
it's a wild idea because most people are
still freaked out about these disruptive
and transformative technologies but in
the end in the end in the end we're
liberating ourselves we're getting rid
of our biological straitjackets you know
we're learning the songs that
orchestrate the universe we're becoming
beings that are in superposition we're
experiencing nonlocality at the level of
consciousness I mean this is us right
we're then realizing the prophecies of
quantum physics it's a wild idea and
something we're thinking about
[Applause]
[Music]